this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality
radio host and best-selling author is my
co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money the ken coleman show is
all about careers
jobs getting one getting a better one
living in your sweet spot but doing
something of purpose that matters
and i can can answer questions about all
of that kind of stuff so you jump in
and we'll talk about your life and your
money and your jobs and your career as
part of that
equation triple eight eight two five
five two two five
is the number that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five
aaron is in new york city to kick us off
this hour what's up aaron
hey thanks so much for taking my call
sure how can i help
so i am on baby step two i have
about 6 000 in credit cards
and a car that's about ten thousand owed
and i am coming into some money about
six thousand dollars from a bonus for my
job and i was curious
if you would consider selling the car i
make about 40
000 a year or if you would just use the
6000 to pay off the credit cards then
pay off the car
b yes use the 6000 pay off the car
unless you just hate the car but uh uh
the car the car is not an unreasonable
car given a forty thousand dollar income
a ten thousand dollar car is not an
unreasonable car
okay we do i i take it you're single
from the language you're using
yes okay and so that is your entire
household income is 40 000 and you have
a 10
000 car correct yes yeah we tell folks
don't have
anything with motors wheels or anything
like that added together
that equals more than half your annual
income because anything with a motor in
it
uh goes down in value and so if all this
stuff adds up you know whereas you've
got a bunch of dead gum toys in your
life
and they're all going down in value you
don't have to scratch your head and
wonder why you're broke we know why
you're broke
toys in other words toys are fine they
just need to be a good ratio to your
income
i got lots of toys but they're a small
percentage of my income
and so you're you're 25 of your income
with this car so yeah throw your bonus
at your credit cards dude uh chop them
up continue to work your baby steps
knock that
car loan out and you're gonna be sitting
in a really really
good shape really good shape so ken
uh the job numbers are you were talking
about it before we came on the air
yeah and this is a um i thought i knew
something i
i'm learning i knew nothing i couldn't i
could
i mean i've got in my mind i've got
states that are wide
open like our state of tennessee's wide
open and then you've got
you know the communist state of
california where everything's shut down
by a draconian governor right and so i
figure the entire economy is just
sitting on the sidelines sitting on
their hands in some of these states
and the economy is booming in the other
states but you're seeing these
numbers coming out the federal numbers
coming out across the whole nation
blending these different states together
obviously in these numbers
the job market is really good it's way
better than you think and here's the
good news dave these numbers say it's
going to
absolutely explode in the next few
months in the next quarter here's where
we are right now
end of february 6.7 million private
sector jobs were posted
that's up from 6.1 million
at the end of december so as we went
into the new year that's how many jobs
so we're
seeing a nice trend in private sector
jobs that are posted
all right and here's the way of looking
at that eight percent more job
openings in february 2021 than there
were in february 2020. now some of you
are going okay i'm trying to remember
when did covet shutdown start
really in march in the month of february
obviously towards the end of february we
were learning new information and things
really ground to a halt in march dave
but we had negative unemployment in
february 3.4
oh we had 3.4 but that's historical that
was the lowest unemployment rate in the
history of the modern era where they
really took
uh those those data and they really
crunched it so we had
the greatest unemployment rate if you
will uh not greatest or the lowest
the best it had ever performed so now
we're seeing more jobs so what we're
seeing is the
united states economy is creating new
jobs so we lost 40 million
jobs in the covent downturn that's right
but
now so what and the unemployment rate
today is what low six as well that's
what it was reported last month we're
waiting on those numbers to come out in
april
i think you're gonna see those numbers
drop into the low fives
you might see it in the four there's no
way to really predict that but based on
so the overall economy from a jobs
perspective has bounced back
it's bouncing back it's not even
finished let me tell you where this is
happening dave
in the areas of manufacturing pharmacy
construction and logistics
and think logistics a lot of technical
jobs there uh you're seeing
50 growth in jobs so what's going to
happen in the next few months
i think we're going to get very close to
where we were in february of 2020
pre-pandemic where
there were more jobs available than
there were people were unemployed
why is this matter well number one
you're getting a steady diet of negative
news all the time that the sky is
falling out because i mean no i don't
even watch the news and i thought it was
worse than that
no and the second thing is understand
folks there are still a lot of states
remember
california new york new jersey just
giving you some examples not a political
statement this is a fact
they're still not fully opened up and if
you look at the hardest hit sector in
the american job
economy was what we'd call leisure so
that would be your bars your restaurants
hotels certainly the airline industry
they're not back so when we see
hopefully
a full comeback in the summer i think
we're going to see one of the greatest
history greatest periods of job
expansion
that means companies offering more jobs
and think of the economy dave and how
jobs that didn't exist a year ago i mean
to a guy that's out there listening who
uh doesn't have a job it means you
better be ready and that's why you need
to come to my get hired event
i just slipped that in there like april
27 no but yeah
but i mean does this mean that that guy
that's out there doesn't have a job
right now
he really should be looking and looking
different and better
because people are hiring and it's
almost it's almost full up it's exactly
right and it's only going to increase so
this
i mean when it's three point something
or four point something unemployment
economists call that full employment yes
even though there's technically people
not working it's like everybody who
wants to work is working and
to your some that don't want to work and
here's what happens in that situation
that we described as last february
people will start to pay you more
the market value for a job goes up we
saw this last year where
young people coming out of college were
getting paid more
than people that were already on the job
and experience why because the demand
this is a supply demand issue just like
in housing
or any other commodity supply demand we
are about ready to move into a place
where it is going to be a
really good environment for the job
seeker for you to get hired and make
more money
bigger shovel get out of debt faster and
position yourself
also works for not only someone who's
sitting there unemployed today but
someone who just wants to change jobs
yes sir
a lot of opportunity a lot of
opportunity i want to make more money i
want to do something different
and so getting qualified right now
getting prepared for this
you've got to have your head on a swivel
the job market's heating up and it's
going to get better
anybody who's intentional about where i
want to go why i want to go there
what i want to do when i get there all
right now's the time
now let's plug the get hired yeah april
the 27th live from our ramsey solutions
studio we're going to have a couple
other people live
uh multiple tickets live stream anywhere
20 bucks to walk them through how to get
hired get clear
get qualified get connected so that
opportunities knock on your door
you can get the job you want the job you
need get out of debt and do work you
love
it's gonna be a great night go get your
ticket ramsay solutions.com
events tickets start at 20 bucks yeah
love to see you there it's a live stream
20 bucks you paid more than that
investment
had more than that for lunch
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality again
host of the ken coleman show doing the
get hired event
if you're feeling stuck or disengaged in
your current job or you dread getting
out of work out of bed to go to work
then uh this event is for you get hired
live stream event on
tuesday 27th at this one night event
you'll learn how to get clear on what
you do best
get qualified for the job you want to
get connected
you can join ken on tuesday april the
27th to take control of your career
and start working toward what you were
born to do tickets start at just 20
text hired to thirty three seven
eight nine hired two three three seven
eight nine
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you screw up or you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free
free samples free shipping and with new
promos all the time always use the promo
code the magic word ramsay
today's question comes from sam in
california he asked my wife and i have
twenty thousand dollars saved for a home
down payment
i currently work in sales but i don't
know what career path i want to take in
the future
should my priority be figuring out the
career question
while we have money saved or should we
purchase a home
and hope career clarity comes later well
this is going to come down to personal
preference
on this but i would not necessarily
forgo buying the house if you save the
money and it's a part of the big plan
i would go ahead and move forward on it
the only exception to that dave
would be when you ask these four
questions about
getting qualified you know you got to
get clear first but once we get clear
and that could take some time
you've got to ask yourself all right so
what education do i need this is not
necessarily mean
a four-year degree or graduate level
degree this could be a certification
uh some basic training that would again
qualify you to do the work you want to
be getting your real estate license
could be that there's a cost associated
so the education question is the first
thing what do i need to learn
the second question is the experience
question what experience do i need
the third question is the economic
question how much is it going to cost me
if i've got to go get some
experience i've got to go get some
education and then the fourth question
is
based on that third economic question is
what's my expectation for how long this
is going to take that's how we come up
with a plan now
if sam does this and he he gets cleared
he realizes okay
i'm gonna need about five to seven
thousand to get qualified to do it he's
got a couple options
they could delay uh putting the down
payment on the home
and use some of that or they could go
ahead and buy the home and then save up
it's going to take some time anyway
so that's what i mean by it's kind of it
depends
but in this situation with you not being
clear i'd go ahead and put the down
payment down on the home
uh and begin to get clear take the
career clarity guide it'll get you
started
uh i don't know in the new career but it
would be really helpful to have a clue
what it looks like
yeah so that going to tell me if i'm
going to go for instance
i mean i think most extreme thing would
be like i'm going to go in the real
estate business you might make
zero money for six months right and you
don't want a brand new house payment
that's right
if that if that's what you're stepping
into so that would tell you
that's right no but so i think clarity
would be very important
before you make the decision because
that's going to tell you if you need to
spend money on education
or if you're going to have an income gap
while you get up and running in the new
gig that's right but once you have that
figured out
if it doesn't prohibit you if it doesn't
use up
too much of your down payment money or
give too big a gap in your income to
make the jump
then you can buy the house and make the
jump later once you know whether it is
you're going and how long it's going to
take you to get there that's the key
so i think i would do that again you
don't have to be in the new career to
buy the house
but you should have a clue this general
vagueness
that's right i don't want you walking in
frustrated two years or a year after you
bought a house and go
i quit you did what we have a house
payment that's exactly right what'd you
do
i'm gonna kill you right and then that's
where the priority thing comes in it
becomes
apparent so again those four questions i
gave that's after you're clear
then you run it out and go what's the
plan to get to where i want to go
that's going to determine the money
question that determines okay
do i want the house now can i cash flow
my qualifying
process and so that's why that works
together always get clear that's stage
one
stage two is get qualified and that's
how that works michael is in atlanta hey
michael welcome to the ramsey show
hey how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
um so i'm currently on baby step two and
i'm starting a process where i do the
debt snowball and really wipe out my
bets
baby step two says you should pay off
all debts except for the house using the
snowball
and in my case i wanted to see if that
would be the scenario my debts are
probably a little higher than average
because i'm running a practice in a
business
okay so what are you what are you
talking about you've got a business debt
that you signed personally for it's a
personal debt
but how much is it ultimately so right
now my practice debt is about eight
hundred thousand dollars
yeah and then my college tuition is
about 185 thousand dollars uh
college tuition you mean student loan
debt correct
yes um student loan debt goes in baby
step two eight hundred thousand dollar
practice
goes in baby step six okay
yeah so you consider that as part of
like the same concept just paying off
the home early then
yeah yeah and i would call it um here's
a here's a kind of a
correlation on that if you will although
the numbers
aren't as many zeros but if you're if
you have a home equity loan we put it in
baby step
two if it's less than half your annual
income
if it's more than half your annual
income we put it in baby step six with
the house
so pray tell please tell me you have an
incredible income with this delicious
mess you've made
luckily the first year of the business
my take home was pushing 250 so
luckily i'm producing more than i'm
spending and i have the ability to
snowball with that
okay so um you said practice what
you're a medical doctor or a dentist a
dentist
excellent okay now the most expensive
form
okay so you netted 250 last year
correct that's my net income what do you
think you're going to get this year
uh i'm aiming up at the 300 but i'm
taking a step at a time with
covered things going all over the place
so we'll see so you're going to try to
live on you're going to try to put at
least 200 a year towards
this mess right that's at least the plan
yeah i'm still living on almost a
college budget i like that
i like that that's hard to do when
you're making a quarter of a million
dollars a year emotionally but it is the
right thing to do and the smart thing to
do
because you have a large mess to go with
your large income
yeah yeah but that's a scary number to
look at so that's my motivation
yeah and i think if you here's what i'd
be looking at
how stinking wealthy you're going to
become instantly when you clear the
table on all this debt
i mean you got a million dollars here in
just student loans and practice it alone
and so when you clear that million
dollars off the top of your head and
you're making three 350
you're gonna make so much money so fast
it's gonna be unbelievable but the
temptation is to drag that out for a lot
of people and that's a
huge mistake we've worked with a lot of
a lot of guys and gals in the dental
world over the years and that's
uh it is
you guys spend more money than mds do on
your practices and on your education
it's it's shocking but the good news is
you got a good practice that you stepped
into so i'm glad for you
yeah play through baby play through good
stuff
wow yeah got to keep the eye on the
prize i hope you folks heard what dave
said
because it's such a huge mountain right
but then you gotta go what's it like on
the other side of that mountain and and
that's when you start piling up money
and you go okay how long do i want to be
a dentist well
25 years well you know you busted over
the next two three years you know four
years backs
really get after it and you're on the
other side of that mountain well it's
really fun
you know once you get up there and you
know i i think of
there's a great story of uh sir evan
hillary who climbed mount everest the
first time and he was with his climbing
partner they finally get up there and
you can imagine how difficult that
journey was way back then he finally
gets up at the highest point in looking
out and that's really this idea of
getting over debt and
and if you get so concerned with how
difficult the climb is
many people fall off but if you're going
hey i want to be the first person to
summit that i'm going to summit that
that's what we're about that's the
vision
when you get up there here's what's
great on the other side of these
debt-free screams that you hear on this
show
people are now looking out they've been
looking up during the journey but then
when you finally get up there and edmund
hillary looked at his friends climbing
sherpa partner he said i think that's
the next one we're going to climb
isn't that amazing on top of the world
five minutes later
i think that's the one we're gonna climb
but now the vision is this way
yeah you start seeing different it's a
different viewpoint
and that's um it is half the battle in
the stuff we talk about around here from
dr john talking about mental health to
money to careers
to uh you know all the different types
of things we get ourselves into around
ramsey
so much of it has to do with the view it
has to do with the perspective
and you know they say that it's easier
to make a second million
sure it is because you've already done
it once and you believe you can do it
it's always easier i know i've done it
twice because i was so stupid i had to
do it twice
there you go this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
this is the ramsey show ali's with us in
omaha nebraska allie my screen says
you're debt free congratulations
thank you dave thank you so much for
having me on today i am so honored to
talk to you
you too how much have you paid off i
paid off 29 173.53
very cool how long did this take yeah
five months on the dot
excellent and your range of income
during that time
yeah so i was right out of school um i
didn't work my senior year
and so i was making you know like zero
dollars um during when i was paying off
debt i made what would have been
equivalent to about 90
and then now i'm back to about the
average for a nurse like 65.70 so
so you just dove in and took all the ot
you could get
i actually did i had two jobs pulled
signs had all kinds of stuff
on facebook i was busy busy for five
months but so you graduated past your
bar and dove in
yeah yeah boards i guess i should say
yeah okay yep
so you what kind of a nurse are you so
um my full-time job is in the nicu
i am at a level four in omaha and then i
do rehab hospitals on the side wow
good for you yeah so what made you so
fired up to knock this out so fast i
mean you're a ball of fire kiddo
yeah thanks um so i had a friend posting
um on his social media about how he had
found you and how
your principles are really changing his
life and i
grew up with a family who um you know we
talked about dave i knew about you
i had gone to college and honestly for
my first three years i was debt free i
was on a full ride scholarship
but then with my nursing degree i
changed institutions
from my prerequisites to my nursing
school and so my scholarship didn't
transfer for my senior year
um and it didn't sit well with me that i
was going to have to take out loans for
that fourth year
so i had already kind of been game
planning how i was going gonna
paid off fast but then i started
researching you and reading your books
and listening to your podcast
honestly obsessively um about christmas
of the previous year and um
yeah the math initially really was what
started the
start of the ball rolling and you know
once i started out of school two i
started having conversations
with my patients and patient family
members
and you know parents in the nicu who
were choosing between
time with their infant in critical care
and going home to their families and
their other children
and just you know it just it became so
much more so quickly
once the journey started it was so easy
to to catch fire and knock it out
so where'd it go man you're on fire how
old are you
thank you um i am 23 i was 22 when i was
paying off all this
all of that how's it feel to be how does
it feel to be free
it's amazing honestly it has um already
had such an impact on my future
to be able to put all of my money um
toward exciting new things you know i am
getting married this fall which i'm
super excited about
um and yes yeah and so we're
like excited to have a debt-free
marriage and starting off in all of
those best ways
we've been able to save for retirement
you know um
it's just it's light you know where a
lot of i feel like my peers are
concerned about the next steps because
there's always the next step and next
thing
i get to look forward to the next steps
and i feel really blessed
wow well because you chose a a hard path
that ultimately ends up being an easier
path
you live like no one else so now you can
live and give like no one else
you're you're an inspiration so what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is you did it you're a
professional
thank you yeah so a big part for me
was the mindset um i just never
let myself even think like i'm tired you
know i'm done with this
because if i did then the defeat road
just came up so quickly so it's really
keeping the mindset
accountability for me was huge um i
think i sent you some pictures of some
post-it notes stuck on my bedroom wall
maybe yeah they're showing up in the uh
on the youtube channel yeah that's
fantastic
yeah yeah so each sticky note
represented two hundred dollars
and initially it was practically from
the floor to the ceiling
and so i would post every two weeks so
i'd make my payment
onto my instagram for all my friends and
whoever to see and it got to the point
where
i was like i'm a night shift nurse so
you know i'd be working
thursday night into friday morning and
coming home and people be messaging me
where's your debt post what have you
paid today
and um so the accountability was massive
for me for that as well
wow well she set up for the first budget
her own group
on instagram oh yeah that's amazing yeah
well done well this is a a key thing
here dave ali i want to congratulate you
and comment on this
and if i've got it wrong that's fine
correct me it doesn't bother me but i
think there's something about the right
applause
when you started posting those things on
instagram and people started paying
attention they said oh ali is doing this
like every week this is showing up
and they see your progress i'm just
curious was the encouragement from
people uh reading those posts was that
also
not just accountability but also some
applause that gave you some juice
totally yeah definitely and especially
when
um you know i did get some messages
while i was paying off on my debt
it was friends saying you know i don't
know where to start i don't know how to
do this
and so you know i was able to call them
and talk through starting of a budget or
a game plan they might be able to attack
i've been passing out your total money
makeover books dave like crazy
um it's been really awesome to watch
everyone else get on fire with me
because it's become kind of this group
shared vision um and yeah i mean
honestly the
encouragement that i got each week was
so awesome i had friends
who are older than me and have gone
through your program before
sending me money for coffee on my way to
my sixth shift
you know and they were just being so
supportive you know like they see how
hard i was working
and um they were so so encouraging so
supportive
you're an amazing young woman i'm so
proud of you very very very well done
well uh we're gonna send you a copy of
rachel cruz's latest book
know yourself know your money uh ken i'm
pretty convinced if we could get about
50 000 alleys going we could change this
whole nation
that's about all it would take we could
tip over all the idiots out there
pretty quick if we had 50 000 it'd be
done yep it changed the whole world way
to go i'm so happy for you you're so
you're so bright so so loud so uh
so so you know just so much coming out
of you it's pretty amazing
very very cool all right ally in omaha
nebraska
29 000 paid off in
five months making 90 to 65.
all the ot and nurse can stand count it
down
let's hear a debt-free scream
all right three two one
i'm set free yeah
wow pretty amazing
i don't want to have a baby in nicu but
if i did and she walked around the
corner things would be a little better
well said wow talk about infectious man
that's smiling just because she's
smiling and you can hear her smile
no question she's fired up man and you
know there is something between that and
and it's amazing over the years of doing
this
this is how we ended up coining the
phrase personal finances 80
behavior it's 20 head knowledge your
behavior flows from
your beliefs that's right you would
never act on something you don't believe
to be true unless you're a psychopath
so otherwise you you know farmers would
never plant seed if they didn't expect
a crop uh and so there's a belief
that causes that behavior that action of
planting
and in her case she believes and
it's amazing to me i i talk to people
making 120 000
a year and they can't figure out how to
pay off 20 000 because eor is their
spirit animal
and then i talk to people like her she's
straight out of college she has zero
money
and passes her boards goes get six jobs
all in nursing at one time
i'm exaggerating but i mean she went
crazy because she just
was on fire yeah i mean she was just
burning at both ends
and and knocks this thing out in 29
months
dave you said something is so huge uh
folks don't miss what he said belief
belief in what you're doing belief that
you can do it but also the belief of
others
i just had the thought i was sitting
there listening her story in today's
world more than ever because of social
media and 24 hour news and the woke mob
and all the things we are so worried
about criticism
what other people say and we ought to be
we ought to not be worried about
criticism we ought to be looking for the
right applause for people who go yeah
you can lose that weight
yes you can pay that debt off yes you
can get that training yes you can get
that job you can do that
we need applause that extra bit of
belief from people who know why we're
doing it and believe that we can do it
is a game changer man if we could offset
some applause for all the trolls
yeah stop worrying about the critics
it's amazing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is host of the ken
coleman show
heard on 75 plus radio stations plus a
podcast and a
ever popular show on sirius xm it's all
about careers and jobs and
finding your purpose so jump in and join
the ken coleman show and you can join
ken today right here
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five brent's with us in boise
idaho hey brent what's up
hey y'all thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help questions for ken
um so i just started um a new job
a month or two ago um and i accepted
my salary and i was happy enough with it
um and then i found out that my
co-workers are making about
50 more than i do like 45
what do you make um and i was wondering
i'm making 22 an hour
doing what uh medical lab scientists
and they're making 33 an hour
oh yeah 32. are they measurably more
experienced than you
no how did you come about this
how'd you get this information
um from them there's
two of us that work on this particular
two others and then me
that we're working on this one we're
dealing with kobe
well i gotta lean i i gotta tell you i i
gotta lean a little bit on dave i got
some thoughts but dave is tired
a lot no no but you've got a unique
perspective on how many people you've
hired and fired in culture development
but i
so so this is really challenging okay
because this is all psychology
and you're human and so you've gotta
you're gonna have to rise above this is
the straightforward answer
uh because if you don't this is going to
eat you alive
and i don't think you'll last very long
uh this is the the natural comparison
uh in comparison is a cancer the only
person i try to compare myself to
is the me of yesterday and and that's
hard
but that's what you got to do because if
if
if you're saying things are equal and
it's an equal playing field they don't
have any more experience than you they
don't have any additional
excuse me certifications or all that
stuff
this is a really nasty situation to find
out about i got to tell you i'm slight
bit
cynical maybe suspect that you got the
information from them i'm not saying
they lied to you but
the whole thing just stinks and if you
want to be there here's the last piece
if you want to be there in the sense
that it's the latter you need to be on
for your career and where you eventually
want to get to and you got to be on this
rung to get to the next rung
then you're going to have to really suck
it up and be the better man here
and and stay out of this kind of stuff
and earn
the next rung if you can't handle that
then you're eventually probably
going to self-select and have to get out
of there and i'm sorry that that's
happened to you because it's a real
devastating psychological blow
it's a really good question you brought
to the forefront here and the
interesting thing about it is your tone
when you're asking the question is not
whiny you're just like it's it's like a
curiosity to you
which is a positive thing so there's not
a you're not angry or bitter or
something like that you're just like
this doesn't make sense it's like a
scientist right i mean it's i
there's a riddle here and so um i'm
gonna join you in the riddle why would
you
if you were to guess why the discrepancy
in pay what would you guess
um because they are i mean
it's a business or hospital they're just
trying to get as little
um or pay as little i came from a
so you don't think it's an oversight um
you know they're you don't think they
saw something different in your
qualifications than the other guy you
don't
think there's a logical explanation
other than just sheer they didn't want
to pay as much and they thought they
could get away with it and they did
and they did i didn't come in i thought
the job was a technician job not a
technologist job
and so when they gave me my pay i was
like well this is really exciting yes
i'll take this because like four bucks
more than i thought it was going to be
um and then i found out what the job
really entailed i
i am a biochemist not a medical lab
scientist
um yeah i've been learning to play golf
and i figured out the secret to
happiness is low expectations
um yeah so yeah you had low expectations
and then you got a four dollars more and
you thought this is wonderful and then
you found out you're ten dollars under
and it's all about expectations what ken
said it's a
psychological problem so what is the
environment like
uh what's the environment like between
you and your supervisor or you're hiring
the person that did the hiring with you
is this a
an open conversational good people
or is it very chain of command real shut
your mouth get your work done
i mean what is it authoritative or
that is a great question um the only
time i've met my supervisor
is the day i was interviewed she went on
leave right after that
and then has since come back from leave
and then never stepped in
and i'm a night shift and so i haven't
uh she's gone before i come in yeah
well i um what i have figured out is
that there is going to be a difficult
conversation
it is going to be in your head and your
head's going to explode
or eventually or you're gonna have a
difficult conversation
and the the trick is how to sit down
with her
and have a difficult conversation and
what uh one of the things we teach
leaders to do and uh you're leading up
in this situation is to just if if
if there's an elephant in the room go
hey there's an elephant over there
don't act like he's not there and so
let's just call out a couple things that
we know here
okay number one when i interviewed for
this job
i first thought it was this and then i
found out it was that
and i was four dollars more than i
thought and so i was really happy
and i'm grateful and by the way i am
grateful for the job
and i have got gotten to talk to you a
lot because you've been out on leave and
of course i'm night shift
but i'm swinging by this afternoon to
have a five minute meeting with you
just uh and i want you to hear nothing
but gratitude from me
um but uh i got to talking to the other
guys in the lab and i found out that i'm
the only guy with the exact same
qualifications it makes
22 and they all make 32. and what i want
to ask you
is what can i do
to make myself worth 32 to you guys
because i'd like to measure up and
apparently i've not done that yet
and that pretty well uh exposes the crap
without you going you people ripped me
off you know
that's the other way to approach it in
which case you just get fired brent
really quick i'm going to jump and ask
this question
are you able to do the market research
and be able to show
that there's a range of income and that
the work you're actually doing
does pay higher can is that is that
something you can find the evidence for
and show that in the marketplace
um there is they are actually above
average what the
other two are making yeah well what i
would do
i would just say all of this yeah number
one i'm happy at 22
i'm not coming in here to gripe about
them making more and number two
i know that the pay around here is above
average in general
but what i'm trying to do is figure out
how i can be more valuable to this place
so that i can be worth it
and you put me in for a 32 instead of a
22.
but i i want to earn it and i want you
to tell me how i can be the best person
i need to be to do that and
i don't want you to hear anything from
me but gratitude listen if
if your boss gets twisted up about that
your boss is an idiot yeah
there's your sign that's not a long-term
stay
yeah the only thing they go shut up and
get in your corner you accepted the job
right then uh then start looking for
another position but but i don't think
they will
i um i think you're bringing it up and
what you're doing is you're exposing the
fact that
all of these facts are here oh by the
way you can also say i accepted the job
at 22.
so i did this deal and i'm so i can't
come in and gripe
about the deal i'm not here to gripe
about the deal i took the job
and uh and so you know the fact that
somebody else makes more does not make
me unhappy
but what i do want to do is i want to
figure out a track that i can get on to
be of value to this place
to where i can join them in that kind of
an income
because that would make me feel really
fulfilled and i would know that i did a
good job for you guys
and that kind of just keep talking about
that way but you know hey i took the job
i i
did the deal so i got no gripes because
i if you'd have been
32 if it had been 42 if it had been you
know whatever number you'd have taken
the job and so you took the job
you know and just admit that admit that
you're you're grateful and that we don't
have a relationship because i'm not
seeing you
and just put all these things that are
facts out on the table so that
that there's nothing swirling around as
a side
of communication that's not happening
be real careful with your body language
your tone and your pacing
and be real calm like you've been with
us and not whiny
if you're octave down no high octaves
this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place
of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show where they
talk about careers and
jobs and finding your purpose he's my
co-host today
so you can ask questions about life
money careers we're here to help you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five alex is gonna start
off the hour in san diego hi alex
welcome to the ramsey show
hello guys thanks for having me on sure
what's up
so um i actually talked to you and karen
a little under a year ago i think it was
in july of last year and
me and my wife we were considering
buying a house but
considering moving soon and what i
didn't really mention at that time is
that we plan to move
for the purpose of serving in the
ministry overseas in europe
we're in our mid-20s and we thought this
was a ways off at the time because we
wanted to have around
around 200 000 in the bank before
leaving just to the safety net because
we didn't know how it worked financially
but my business has really taken off in
the past year or so and we've been able
to save up a lot more so we really want
to use this as a blessing
to get that ministry started started
sooner we'll be providing for ourselves
uh the church will not be helping us
which we're okay with
but we will be taking a pretty big pay
cut so that should allow us to take care
of our expenses and retirement but not
much else
my question is just kind of a rocking
chair uncle dave type of question
you know can you give me any financial
advice i should be thinking about and
just kind of talk me through
you know having mental peace with taking
a pay cut providing for myself and my
wife
um because it just kind of freaks me out
cutting our our salary kind of in the
or i guess our income you know that by
more than two-thirds
yeah do you own a business yeah i do
what are you gonna do with that gonna
keep it going i have some employees
um that i've been training and they're
gonna help me take over a good portion
of my workload so i'll be working maybe
10 to 20 hours a week instead of
you know 40 to 50. why would you pay
yourself less then just remotely right
yeah it's going to be remotely are you
expecting the income from the business
to go down
no i don't think so um but you know i'm
hoping by the time that we leave the
people that i have
working for me kind of part time they're
ready to step into a full-time
oh so your expenses are going to go up
your net profit is going to go down
exactly yeah okay now i understand all
right because you're hiring people to
know what you might come down a little
bit i don't know but
you know i i don't know how long do you
think you're going to be in the on the
mission field
uh we're looking at a minimum of two to
three years
but we'll reassess it with you know at
that point
okay well that gives me a lot of peace
you ask about peace
um i mean obviously if god's hand is on
this and god called you to this that
gives you a level of peace
um but it doesn't mean that missionaries
don't fa that are called
don't face uh financial struggles most
of them do as a matter of fact
uh it's a hard it's a hard life you're
signing up for it's a tough thing
um and yet it's one of the most
rewarding things probably you can do on
the planet if you're called to it
so and you obviously are i'm not
questioning that
the sec but but from a uh less of a
spiritual lens but more of an emotional
psychological lens if you can see the
end of something
you can walk through anything with peace
um if you can say it's going to be over
here it's the perpetual thing that
drives people nuts
the ambivalence and so even if it's pain
you can say okay this pain is you know
doc says i'm you know this is
i'm going to start this procedure and
it's gonna
really hurt for 30 seconds but obviously
five years from now you're going to be
well because of this 30 seconds of pain
you can endure the 30 seconds of pain
but if he just starts cutting on you you
know how long it's going to be
i mean that pain eats you alive
psychologically so
if you could see the end of it and so i
would set a time i would say
we're going to commit to two years three
years whatever the mark is
and at that time we're committing to
moving back home
and ending this mission now
we will stay keep ourselves open to the
fact that god asks us to stay and we
feel called to stay
and so on but for right now our our
level of commitment is a three-year
commitment at the end of that we're
coming back home
see if you set that that gives you a
sense of uh
destiny a sense an end to this a light
at the end of the tunnel that's not an
oncoming train
financially or mathematically and then
you can
scrape and claw and scratch and
sacrifice for that period of time
uh but but eventually you got to come up
for air you can't hold your breath but
for so long
so the it's the ambivalence that drives
people nuts the lack of clarity
alex i thought i heard you say that the
company made more money so you're moving
the timeline up to go to the mission
field is that correct
yeah yeah we have a good we have a
really good safety net of just kind of
our
fixed amount in the bank but and i
understand me ask you this money coming
in month over month and it kind of
freaks you out
but here's my question for you do you
feel god's pressed a call to
to move the timeline up or do you are
you just reacting to
this timeline based on well when i we
said we were going to move on and move
when we hit this goal financially i'm
just wondering what's driving the
increased timeline because we hit the
number we planned or do you feel a press
to go
and i've got a follow-up question so is
it yes or no on that
yeah no i mean i feel uh i felt a bit
pressure and weight of helping in this
ministry for a long time
but honestly the goals that we set
financially were not necessary
it just kind of felt like a secular
safety net not even that made me feel
bad and now being way beyond that
i just feel even more of the burden of
it because i feel like
you know i have to go do this all right
so i think you got to listen to that uh
and i think
i think you got to honor that and i
think what dave said is right the only
thing i would tell you is is that i i
would not assume
that just because you're taking on the
increased cost of employees because
that's real
that the company wouldn't grow and i
would do everything i could to see if we
can keep those revenues going and really
dive in and then just and then and then
i think god's gonna bless you
regardless uh but i just wouldn't assume
that all of a sudden
um the company won't grow uh i try to
train those folks and
and stay in tune in those 10 hours
whatever you're doing try to lead them
and see if god doesn't bless that and
grow that business my schedule you know
maybe a little bit of extra you guys to
schedule a uh an occasional two-week
move back here to sit around and do
things for two weeks in the company and
then go back
and give it a little booster shot
missionaries do that all the time yeah
up they come back to raise funds you're
going to come back to run the businesses
that's supporting since you're
self-funding and keep you know that
you're self-funding that's a great
point you don't have to stay there the
entire time and work remotely
10 hours a week and so you can run back
and forth a little bit it's not that
hard and
um uh but yeah i i think if you see
things
less permanent and more flexible it
keeps you from losing your piece
to answer your question and so i would
add the flexibility of some returns and
i would put a deadline on it that um
you know that unless you know my wife
and i both hear from god
then we're coming home after three years
and so
uh or whatever and you can pray and
determine that deadline in prayer i
don't care
but it i i think leaving the door open
and we're going to just stay until
dot dot that'll drive you bananas unless
you're
planning to be a full-time missionary
the rest of your life which you did not
tell me that you told me otherwise which
means he could also they could both come
back
keep that business viable and growing
and continue to go back over time take
their kids back it becomes a
generational thing
it's a both end it doesn't have to
always be all in it doesn't have to be a
you know a one-year mission trip and
then you're done forever and it doesn't
have to be a
you're on the field forever and you
never come back to the states um
so we just have better transportation
and technology these days
so it's a cool thing you're doing
brother thanks for letting us
participate
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today have you ever asked
questions like how much
should i be saving how much debt
should i be paying off and how can i do
it faster or what's the right way to
invest the good news is you don't have
to figure out the answers on your own
ramsey plus which includes financial
peace university
will guide you every step of the way
with the ramsey plus membership you get
all the digital teaching you need to
really understand money so you can be
confident that you're always doing the
next
right thing see not knowing what to do
is the biggest problem
knowing what to do and then having the
motivation to do it is the easy part
we can show you that our world-class
budgeting app
every dollar our tools our guided action
steps to help you make progress on your
money fast
it means no more debt it means cash in
the bank when there's an emergency
and a real plan for your future ramsey
plus helps you get small
consistent wins every day that lead to
big results
and lifelong habits to get started with
a free trial text
trial to 33 789
that's trial two three three seven
eight nine ryan is with us in starkville
mississippi
hi ryan how are you good how are you dad
better than i deserve what's up so me
and my fiancee
are both 22 years old graduating college
both from mississippi state at the end
of the month
wonderful what are your degrees in i'm
in construction management and she is
elementary ed
excellent when are you getting married
uh
november or september 10th good for you
glad you got i'm glad you got it
straight
yeah all right september 10th big day
man congratulations
i appreciate it my question is
so neither of us will have debt uh my
parents helped me pay
my way through college uh and she
had a full-ride scholarship through
excellence in teaching program
so she just has to teach mississippi for
five years after graduation
um we'll have just under a hundred
thousand dollars
of joint income once we're married
um and i will both be living
with family so very little expenses till
then so plan on saving
as much as we can until we're married
our question is do we need to
look at renting as our first housing
option or should we look at buying since
we're both step three and
have that leg up on song well you
financially meet the guidelines that we
give you for buying we tell you to be
debt free have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses before
you buy
and then buy a 15-year mortgage with a
payment no more than a fourth
of your take-home pay on a fixed-rate
15-year mortgage
that's the guidelines that we use now i
will tell you
as a a dad of 20 somethings and
30-somethings
and has having coached folks for 30
years i
personally think you will make a much
better housing decision
if you wait one year and so i would be
per i would be looking for homes uh this
time
next year into the summer with the idea
of closing in september
one year on your one year anniversary
give or take it takes about a year
of living together as a married couple
to know how close to your mother-in-law
to buy
you have to get you have to get to know
each other to make a better decision
right now there's a lot of wonderful
milestones happening in your life
you you know you would not be human if
you didn't have stars in your eyes
uh you know you're getting married
you're graduating you both got good
careers you're debt free man what a
wonderful
start you've got yes everything's great
here
it's not going to kill you if you buy a
house but i think you'll buy a different
house
one year from marriage than you would
have today
and if you start your real estate career
at 23 24 years old instead of 22 years
old
that is not the end of the world you are
still going to be wealthy
you're still going to be fine you
haven't thrown the money away you've
just concentrated on your marriage spend
the first year concentrating on your
marriage a hundred percent
don't there's an old thing in the old
testament in the bible that
they they would not allow a soldier to
go to war
in the first year of marriage and the
first year of marriage they had to stay
home and get the home solid before they
went off to war of course they were
often gone
for years at a time when they went off
to war but so it's a little different
but
but it's a it's a principle coming out
of second kings
ryan here's a little secret that when
you become a homeowner you start owning
problems that happen with that home
and i think that dave has nailed this i
think that in addition to what he said
is
to have a year of just renting a nice
apartment you guys can afford it and
enjoy just
living together and learning what kind
of a home do we want and dave
said so beautifully there that that is
going to become more clear
uh a year later but you know you don't
need the additional stress
that comes with marriage uh dealing with
new
jobs new jobs new marriage we're sharing
silverware and mustard yeah come home
hang out at the pool at the apartment
complex be young and married with no
kids and chill
and just not have to think about you
know the gutters the gutter doesn't
agree with that
heat and air is not working that's what
nobody tells you you got to put up
curtain rods which that
that by the way is the third largest
cause of divorce yes
true but um that's true
because here's why in in in stacy's
house
her dad did it this is a true story my
wife we've been married almost 23 years
in my house and he knew how to run a
screwdriver he knew how to do it well
something that something i do something
mr coleman might not know how to do
no talent in that area but you do you
learn those things what time do we eat
dinner
you see dinner this time in my house who
does what my dad used to fill the
dishwasher you know
who knows you got all these cultures you
roll the toothpaste or squeeze it yeah i
mean there's a lot of major
philosophical things that have to be
are you and sharon in alignment on how
to handle the tube of toothpaste this is
what people want to know
yeah you are yeah we each have our own
and separate ends of that
massive bat master bedroom bathroom
that's the right answer that's where we
had to go and that way she doesn't get
in my way right
right yeah you know that's how it went
down
yeah i didn't want to agree with that no
you better not no
uh you me stacy will all be in trouble
uh so yeah you're that but i mean it's
it it's a
there is nothing wrong with and you're
gonna you ryan you're gonna get
tremendous pressure from all these
financial geniuses that aren't
you know you're just throwing your money
away you need to go bye bye bye
bye bye and it's okay yeah i'm not
suggesting you go a decade without home
ownership i'm talking about 12 freaking
months
and let this thing have a little breathe
a little rhythm to it
and that's just an opinion and it's
probably worth what you paid for it but
i feel pretty strongly about that i tell
young couples
that are getting married wait at least a
year to buy a home
you got enough other things you got to
adjust in your life to get square on
good stuff good question sarah is with
us sarah's in dayton ohio hi sarah how
are you
doing well my question is um i want to
know if i'm taking out enough money
investing enough so that when i retire i
can have money to blow
okay how much are you investing okay
so my husband my husband takes out um
it's about 625 a month into deferred
comp and i take 300
out of a month of our paychecks into our
deferred comp
how old are you um i'm 37 he's 36.
he has about 120 000 in his and i only
have about 15
000 in mind and every year
we plan on adding an extra 25 to it
it just depends on how much you plan to
blow
but you're gonna you should you should
have millions of dollars with what
you're outlining
okay just because i want to be able to
you know just up and leave and go
wherever i want or you know
take a depends on wherever you want i
mean
are you upping and leaving and jumping
on your own 747
jet uh the contest that cost a hundred
million dollars and you're gonna live in
on the beach in you know buy some of the
most expensive real estate in the world
no
you're not gonna have that much money
but you're gonna have millions
wait you're gonna have millions yeah if
you wanna go to cancun and stay in an
all-inclusive with a couple friends
you'll be able to afford it
okay now that i can handle i just if we
just keep adding 25
extra every year to it yeah but here's
the thing
here's the thing you need to probably
reset some of this stuff
and uh i'll send you a copy of the total
money makeover you need to be doing
a deferred comp is the last one you
would do the first one you would do
is anything like a 401k with a match and
anything that's roth
is second and traditional investments in
401ks and iras are third
deferred comp would be fourth and you
probably have other options available
that will serve you better in these
goals
and of course we're going to get you out
of debt before you do any of that
so hang on i'll send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover which will
walk you through exactly what to do
and exactly when to do it hold on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today ken our favorite thing to
do on the show is a debt-free scream
our next favorite thing that's a little
bit better is to do a debt-free scream
live in the lobby but the best of all
debt-free screams are our own
ramsey team members doing their
debt-free screams on the debt free stage
right here in the lobby with half the
freaking company not working standing
out here watching
yeah that's awesome so very cool you're
happy when they're not working
well you need to step in well that's
true we need to celebrate yeah we need
to solve it that's right then we're
going to get right back to work
so jim nally is with us he's been with
us about four years and is a
director of paid media a digital
marketing team is uh here with your
with his wife and your wife's name is
amanda amanda well welcome guys
congratulations you did
it you did it how much did you pay off
and how long did it take
we paid off two hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars for five years
five years that's amazing and you've
been here four years
so you've been in the middle of serious
positive peer pressure for a long period
of time
as a part of this i mean what better
environment to make you do this stuff
and uh so i'm so proud of you guys
that's a long
slog tell us the story what happened
five years ago that started the process
and in the middle of or in early in the
process you end up here yeah yeah so
we um originally took fpu right at eight
years ago
and it was in the middle of a season of
just
hard hard times we had uh just had a
baby who's born 10 weeks early
we're barely making any money and we had
started floating some bills between some
credit cards and had a massive amount of
student loan debt
so of the 217 about 150 or 160 with
student loan debt wow what was the rest
of it
about 40 was medical and then kind of a
smattering of small consumer things on
top of that
so a mountain of debt no income to
amount to anything
baby comes early yep it's like the
perfect storm yeah
yeah yeah and we believed it and we
started to
to work it but in very like baby baby
steps yeah
actually working the baby steps yet
crawling yep yep so very kind of davish
we were still floating between the
credit cards but we were trying to stick
to a budget and then when it when it
wouldn't work we'd get frustrated and
we'd jump way back to that spot of not
wanting to open the bank account again
being terrified of what what was lurking
kind of anytime we'd pull that screen up
and
a few years later well why don't you
tell that part of it yeah so about five
years ago is when we really kicked into
gear
um it was about christmas time and i
remember
we were trying to get presents together
and we had two small kids at that point
and
we were scraping the other pennies for a
loaf of bread to eat dinner
i mean it was that bad um and i remember
walking through the grocery store
and there were these carolers singing
through the grocery store and i'm just
crying like why are you so dead-coming
and um and i was just like i went home
and i can't we can't do this anymore
we cannot do this anymore i was sick and
tired of being sick and tired amen
and so we started working it yeah we
busted out our copy of total money
makeover
pulled out every dollar started just
getting back on it again
basically reset on our snowball because
it had been in a couple
spreadsheets and then we're like nope
let's fresh start from today
let's get it figured out and then it's
just been hustling ever since yeah
and how'd you end up here yeah so um we
have been in the nashville area about 10
years i used to work down the street
from the old office
and uh walt yates one of our uh
vps now reached out to me
and said hey you wanna come chat have
coffee and then uh and kind of a miracle
of hiring here ten days later had an
offer and was
starting my new role and since then the
team has grown from just me to a team of
ten
and we're looking for a lot more digital
marketers out here too absolutely it's
been a
been a wild ride for the last four years
yeah that is a miracle of you standing
out here that got hired how many of you
took longer than 10 days raise your hand
everybody
all of them yeah that never happens it's
harder to get on with the fbi than it is
us but uh yeah
yeah we're pretty choosy because we
don't want crazy in the building so
way to go man so cool and you've obvious
your career here i've followed you i
know who you are and what you're doing
and you've done a great job here and
uh have continued to advance in this
place
and um and and i'm we're not going to
ask your incomes during this time
because your co-workers are standing
around that's what i like to do
but but um but you guys have done an
incredible incredible job
five years yeah wow
yeah how's it feel it honestly hasn't
even quite
hit us yeah it's this like i'll have
moments of just being busy and then
things
get quiet for a moment and then i'm like
whoa like everything's changed
there's this just kind of sense of awe
and a real sense of like god was
reminding me this week i've brought you
this far
wait until you see what i do today yeah
just wait
the next chapter is going to be awesome
yeah
this is so cool yeah amanda that was uh
you need to write that story of the
grocery store out to be able to hand it
to your daughter on
the you know three weeks after she gets
married
so she she can know where how her family
tree was changed
because that was sharon sharon used to
say
people say you know how much money you
want she said i just want to be able to
go to the grocery store
and buy a full buggy that's all i want
and truthfully that that has satisfied
her for a very long time
you know it's just she really didn't
change that i mean she there's we bought
lots of other things but
you know that that was kind of like a
measure that we weren't desperate and
freaked out anymore
if we could just go to the grocery store
and buy a whole buggy of groceries i
mean
babies running around all that so such a
great
great job you guys very very well done
who are your biggest
cheerleaders um our our parents my
parents
are here today with us hey that's
awesome cheering us along the way jim's
parents too
they just weren't able to make the trip
but um also our
church family you know we had a small
group of people that
what church are you in uh we've been
going to
um well it's complicated
okay just move on let's move on that's
right
there are several great churches in the
area there's a lot of great churches
just leave it alone we're good
okay so your cheerleaders were your mom
and dad of course you had a couple
cheerleaders on the team i'm sure
folks on the team knew what you're doing
absolutely we all talk about this stuff
all the time we really actually do the
things we teach we do around here it's
probably amazing yeah
pretty crazy yeah our whole theme for
the internal team this year is to walk
the talk we got t-shirts everywhere
teaching financial piece university of
the team
again this year and and just getting
everybody involved and everybody winning
and
i'd be ashamed to work here and not not
do this stuff you know
so proud of you guys i gotta ask you
when you do something
for a year two years and that's intense
commitment
five years is next level and i heard you
say you know i'm still
recalling that hey we're actually debt
free i want you to talk to people who
are feeling like they're in the middle
of that run
they're in that they're going they're
stupid we feel like we're halfway
through and it's
really really hard and it feels like
even though we know we've made
progress it doesn't feel and seem like
we're ever gonna get there what do you
say to those folks
yeah the biggest thing even as we're
just reflecting the last few days
um when you hit a wall when you
have a month where you don't quite hit
your budget when you have something that
comes up
unexpectedly sets you back when you're
on a journey that long the biggest thing
is just to keep making progress like
look at progress not perfection i can't
tell you how many times
i can't tell you how many times we hit
the like oh we missed it this month and
then
our first instinct is to shut down and
not want to look at it again not want to
pick it back up but being able to just
pick it back up
time after time and sometimes there's
longer gaps on those times and sometimes
it's shorter
yeah the other thing i'd say is don't
put off especially if it's going to be
this long
don't put off the things to take care of
your mental and spiritual and relational
health yeah like we've both
been to see some counselors and that
sort of thing along the way and it was
critical to take care of our
our souls and our families that's good
absolutely while we're taking care of
our finances thank you very much
and you brought the uh brought the
kiddos through the debt-free scream with
you their names and ages
yeah we have sarah she is about to turn
nine she's over a little preemie
all right here healthy today and this is
judah he's six
all right very cool and i'm sure they've
been practicing their debt free school
oh yes
all right it's sarah and judah amanda
and jim he's a director of paid media
here digital marketing team looking for
some more team members just like him and
a pretty incredible story jim we're so
proud of you guys 217
thousand dollars paid off in five years
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
how fun is that man they cleared up a
bunch of that
that was a lot this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five calvin's in los
angeles hi calvin
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave huge
respect for you guys do
thank you have a quick question okay i'm
uh 22 years old
recently graduated from college and just
starting my career
uh i currently live at home but i've
been saving
everything i make and i have a good
amount saved up right now and i want to
purchase the house
but living in los angeles housing prices
are just
astronomical and i just don't see myself
being able to afford one
anytime soon i wonder if you have any
advice on if i should just get out of
la or any way i could possibly become a
homeowner anytime within the next few
years
hmm well it's a
you know obviously you've analyzed the
situation correctly it's an expensive
market and in order to buy a home there
you're going to have to have a
pretty substantial income what do you do
i'm a manager currently at a warehouse i
make about 70 000 a year
your phone's cutting in and out you make
about what a year
i make about 70 000 a year as a manager
at a warehouse
okay what's the career path you
mentioned possibly moving for your
career what's it look like moving up the
ladder 10
15 20 years down the line well the
company i'm working at is expanding
pretty rapidly so there is definitely a
good opportunity where i'm at i'm
enjoying the work
so i could see myself and i do believe
in the next few years
my income will increase and they have a
lot of opportunities out of state so
i'll be open to moving
i'm just a little nervous about i've
lived in l.a my whole life
going somewhere new yeah well that would
be human
um most people would be nervous about
doing something new it's also an
adventure
it can be it can be exciting and scary
simultaneously
and here's the thing you don't you do
not have to look at
a move as a permanent equation
you're 22 23 years old so you could take
a job making 70 000
with the exact same company in another
city where real estate prices are half
what they are there
and start your life there's nothing to
say that five years later you don't take
a job in la
and move back you know there's nothing
to say you don't end up in
whatever city you know after that but
there's um
uh i i would challenge you to say you
know some people when they're 22 and
they graduate from college they go
backpacking in europe for a year for an
adventure and don't do anything
except see europe which is kind of cool
a little hippie-ish but kind of cool
but instead you could just say my
adventure is going to be another city
for four years
yup i love that i'm going to pile onto
what dave's saying this is a great idea
i would take the top three cities you
said there were some opportunities for
you to make money what are those
potential promotions what cities do
those exist in
and then let's say there's three cities
four cities five cities
uh you're a single guy you've got some
vacation time go visit go visit the city
yeah that's good
it's not so scary when we actually go
see it and
uh hang out a little bit into dave's
point now we go wait i can move this
city move up
i'm making more money what area of town
do the 22 year old 23 year olds live in
and
you know which is really the cool end of
town typically right but i mean there's
some really neat cities in america
uh and you can enjoy some you'd enjoy
three or four weeks of good travel
uh or three or four weekends long
weekends of good travel or something and
see some of these areas and then
see what your company can open up for
you you're not in a hurry but you're
not nailed down you're more free and
mobile
today than probably you ever will be
again in your life
that makes a lot of sense i'll tell you
this too calvin you may not believe how
free it is in some other cities
guys in los angeles they've truly been
on lockdown yeah i mean can't even walk
outside
for a while yeah it's gonna um yeah yeah
and covet stuff aside but yeah but but
yeah i'm just going to see this time as
an adventure i love it i don't think
your only path
is try to make uh 150
000 so that you can afford a home in la
you know uh it's going to be hard to do
a home in la
uh you know with a typical income
considering the real estate prices are
not
typical and so you i mean you're sitting
about that
household average in america the good
news is you're only 22. so you're going
nowhere to go from here but up usually
so good stuff there but um i just i'd
have some fun with this
lee is in chattanooga hi lee how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um my husband and i we are debt free
and we are currently maxing out both of
our roth
and we have a my husband has a simple
um ira at work that he contributes to
the match on it
and so i was just wondering what are
what are our other options as far as
investing
for retirement and just regular
investing in general
um okay very good so i would max out
anything that he's got at work
if he's got a simple and he's only doing
the match then i would go ahead and take
it all out to the max
that's the first thing because it's a uh
a simple ira is a 401k at a small
company
yeah that's what it amounts to and they
have a mandatory three percent match
and so that that's what he's
experiencing they probably offer that
in a roth and i'd be doing it in a roth
as well
so if you can do a simple with a match
fully funded as a roth and do your two
roths that's the first step
uh or something that sounds something
like that uh
and are and you're not working outside
the homely
i know i'm not okay all right do either
one of you have any self-employed income
i know okay all right uh then you're
left with just
open market investing now uh what is
your household income
um about 85. okay well we recommend
putting
15 percent of your household income
which in your case uh a couple of roths
would do it
yeah we're pretty much there now but
we've still got some extra
that comes in well i know but do you
have a
is your home paid off it is yes
you did that in january that's wonderful
okay then you're just left with
investing
and uh okay you know at this point um
what you're what what i would suggest
you do is just open a
uh probably something that's called a
low
turnover mutual fund if you're working
with the smartvestor pro they can help
you with that
another way to access a low turnover
mutual fund
is a uh just an s p 500
index fund now i'll explain to you what
that means okay
if you buy a stock a single stock let's
just say you bought i'll make up a
number
a 50 stock and i'll call it home depot i
don't even know what home depot sells
for but let's just call
you bought the stock for 50 if it goes
up in value
from 50 to 70 you do not pay taxes
on the sev on the 20 increase until you
sell it right okay
it's a cold account it's a capital gain
if you hold it more than a year
so it's taxed at less than regular
income
and you don't pay taxes on it until you
sell it that's called
realized but not recognized
you've realized the gain but you've not
had to recognize it for tax purposes
and uh so if you buy a low turnover
mutual fund the mutual fund has a bunch
of stocks in it
and they almost never sell them if they
have a 5
turnover ratio 95 of them did not sell
and all of the growth on the 95 that did
not sell
is just like that 50 to 70 there's no
tax
due on it until you sell it so the
beauty of it is
it's tax deferred capital gains growth
in mutual funds but it's not in a
retirement plan
so it's it's a good it's a very tax
efficient way
to grow your money i personally do that
a lot i dump a ton
into index funds and then when i get a
chunk in there i buy a piece of real
estate that i pay cash for
and then i start again then i build it
up again because i like real estate
but if you just wanted that was maybe an
option
in the you know in the future once we
get a chunk of money so yeah if you had
enough to pay cash for a little rental
house here in chattanooga that'd be
awesome right
and get your real estate portfolio
started and that going along with your
roths and his simple
you're going to be in really really good
shape and you don't have to do anything
fancy
again a smartvestor pro clicksmartvester
daveramsey.com any of you that are
willing to do your investing
they can show you how to do this stuff
and teach you so you understand what
you're doing
never do something you don't understand
but that's how that works and it's the
most tax efficient way
uh and a beautiful beautiful way to do
your your surplus
investing portion ken good hour yeah
always fun
good cause ken coleman ramsey
personality my co-host today james
childs is our producer kelly daniels our
associate producer and phone screener
i am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa
google assistant or siri to play the
ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host ken coleman ramsey personality host
of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two
five ian starts us off this hour in
knoxville
hi ian welcome to the ramsay show
dave and ken thank you so much for
having me on the show how are you today
better than we deserve what's up brother
all right so i'm in the middle almost
halfway through a master's degree
and i'm taking on death if i continue i
will take on more debt
i know your policy on student loans and
i just happened to work at a job that
like
i'm a teacher at a private school and
in order for me to maintain my position
here i have to show that i'm making
progress
towards life insurance through this
master's program
my question is do i stay in the master's
degree
and continue to take on debt or should i
get out of it
but then have to look for a different
job what do you think
so the master's degree you're a high
school teacher
yes sir private school no sir i'm a
middle school teacher at a
private person school and they demand
that you are going into debt and
taking on to get a master's degree to
teach middle school kids
well they that's kind of right
um that's a good way of putting it
yeah these are eighth graders for god's
sakes i mean i'm not against education
but this is a little bit onerous
so uh so how much debt have you taken on
all right so so far i have 11 200
in debt and if i continue i estimate at
least
15 000 additional dollars in debt
okay are you married yes sir i am does
your wife work outside the home
uh she has a job but it's one that she
can work from at home she actually just
got it
we're unsure it's commission based we're
unsure what that's going to look like
month to month
what do you make so i make 32 000
a year do middle school teachers in the
public school system make more or less
uh they make more i mean the price vary
the amount varies by
district overall it's more yeah i was
thinking knox county would pay better
than that
i i got to ask here for clarification is
this a part of your employee agreement
when you signed on where they say you
have to have continuing education to
stay employed here
that's correct
what's the long-term goal for you as a
teacher where do you want to end up
what's it look like in the future where
are you headed
well for this is kind of what i'm
thinking right now for many years i've
wanted to be a teacher um my wife and i
we've just
started to get out of debt and we're
reading through one of your books days
and so we want to be we're going to have
financial freedom obviously
and i've just read and heard over and
over that you're
like you're a dance student you're
against that of any
you know in any form and
and like i'm willing to do whatever it
takes i'm like if i have to find a
different job like i will uh if it's
worth it to
continue like well this is not about
this is not about me
this is about what gives you your best
life
a decade from now and is that student
loan debt
is it this career track is it this place
that you're working in
um aside from anything you've learned
from us
just commenting you know just as your
friend looking in from the outside
you are underpaid in a private school
setting what you could be paid in a
public school setting
and they're putting extra rules on you
that make it super unreasonable
um that's aside from dave ramsey or
ramsey solutions
things am i am i missing something ken
no i i mean
the question i was asking is ian do you
want to be in education long term
because that kind of plays into this i
would certainly pause the master's
degree
i would where do you want to be in 10
years yeah
like in terms of my jobs yeah i mean up
until
this year i thought it was it was
teaching but after
going through the numbers i'm like like
i could be paid
i could get paid way more provide for my
family and still do something i enjoy
for less hassle yeah but here i want to
caution you on that and i understand
those emotions
but but if you always felt the call to
be a teacher and you want to instruct
you love instructing
um then number one you can make more
than you're making right now
number two uh we have a study the
largest study
ever of net worth millionaires and the
third largest group of net worth
millionaires in the united states are
teachers so you can take care of your
family you can retire a millionaire so
if that's true and you believe that
would that give you reason to leave
being a teacher
you said would that be a reason to yeah
my point is if if you know you could
take care of your family and retire a
millionaire
would that make you want to leave being
a teacher if you knew you could provide
and take care and
retire wealthy would you leave
like it would definitely make like make
me consider it
much more as an option yes knowing that
does help so
i think you need to look at being a
teacher somewhere else
that's right you're doing the right
thing in the wrong place
and so you need to if they're going to
fire you upon quitting
which i don't know how stringent this is
then you need a plan i don't want you
jumping here but if it were me i'd pause
and move on to
start talking the county and the city
school system about coming on there or
another private school
and you maybe you're working your way up
to i don't know what are the best paid
teachers in the land
how do you do this and what i know i
have a friend that's
in a county school system that made 90
000 a year 30 years with a master's
degree
but a specialized area of teaching not
just
in the the traditional classroom but in
a public school system
uh working with um you know k-12
and so uh not to reveal any more than
that but uh um
and so uh you know uh my aunt
taught at farragut and i don't know what
she made but she was there for 38 years
right around the corner from you there
so i know the school system there and i
know knoxville and
uh so do you want to be teaching middle
schoolers high schoolers where's the
best money where's the best reward for
you psychologically spiritually what's
god asking you to do with
while you're on the planet or do you
continue your education path and even
at some point with a phd end up in a
college classroom
which i suspect pays more than the high
school classroom i don't know for sure
it would depend on the college versus
which high school
but i think you develop a path that is
not thirty two thousand dollars
with a forced set of rules um
ten years from now uh it could be you
stay there for a year
and you ask them for some mercy because
you're having to stop your masters
you know right now you don't have the
money to complete it uh and you ask them
for a little mercy
meantime you start looking for a job and
move to a different teaching gig that's
probably what i'm gonna do but i want to
kind of start thinking about
what does the mountain look like what
does the path on the mountain look like
and what's the top of the mountain look
like as ken talks about that to get
clear
on where you're going get promoted along
the way but
you need to develop a system i'm going
to do work this many years in high
school this many years in the college
classroom
this many years i don't care where you
want to end up or where god's telling
you end up
but i think that this has revealed not
a lack of burden for teaching but a bad
situation yes
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
we're so glad you're with us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five this is common sense for your
dollars and cents ken and i are the two
ornery uncles that'll give you the
advice you always needed
i like that you never know everybody had
some ordinary uncles right hungry uncle
ken i'm going to own that
with my niece and nephews uncle ken
there we go that's a new one
summer is where this summer is uh in
cincinnati hi summer how are you
i'm great how are you doing guys doing
today better than we deserve what's up
i'm so glad to be talking to the two
only uncles
yes there's like two of those old men
muppets
yeah my question is
um my father-in-law passed away a few
months ago
and um since that time
my mother-in-law has been um dealing
with her finances on her own
they have plenty of money they've never
had debt and they're very blessed
um which she called my husband last week
and told him
that she wanted to gift us twenty
thousand dollars to
put toward it
we're having trouble hearing you summer
can you speak directly into your phone
she wants to give you twenty thousand
dollars to do what
she wants to give us twenty thousand
dollars to put toward
an above ground pool for the kids and
also
a barn for my husband because he is
inheriting a workshop full of tools and
equipment
and other things um so my first reaction
was
we're in baby step two by the way um we
should be finished with babysitting in
october we've been on the journey for 15
months we have 21 000 left to go yeah
so i thought we should take the money
and put it towards maybe 50
um because we were going to save in the
future
other items your phone is all over the
place
we have real trouble hearing you if you
can stabilize it somehow it'd be great
okay i'm sorry um so i thought we should
put the money towards baby step two
my husband thinks that we should use the
money
um as my mother-in-law has given us
for wishes what do you think i think you
shouldn't take the money
okay at all
here's what's going on your husband and
his mom
are grieving they're hurting
and they're not thinking clearly
okay he's he's he's lost his dad he's
got all his dad's tools coming
that he probably used to work in the
garage with his dad
and that brings back a lot of memories
and he's trying to rebuild that portion
of that memory because of it because
he's hurting he lost his dad and how
long were the how long were
your mother-in-law and him married 50
years
yeah i mean she just lost
like her right arm and her right leg you
know i mean i've been married to sharon
38 years
i don't need to be making decisions like
this two months after sharon's gone
my brain's not gonna be working good and
your mother-in-law your mother-in-law is
a very sweet person
and she's hurting deeply
okay and so you need to love her gently
and kindly and just say you know what
this is not a good time
for us and it's not a good time for her
and by the way even your husband you
need to tell that to
and he needs to take care of his mom you
don't need to say a word to her
because you'll get painted in the
ungrateful daughter-in-law position if
you're not careful
okay yeah she's just hurting honey and
because this is truthfully her
suggestions are ridiculous
the last thing you need is more expenses
while you're in debt
and an above-the-ground pool does not
add value to anything
it's useless for the property it's good
for fun
but it does not add value to the
property it may as a matter of fact
detract
value from the property and
it has to be maintained the money i
spend on my in the ground pool
makes me want to throw up per hour we
swim in it
you know it's crazy we don't need an
extra expense right now
well we'll do it with our own chemicals
well you gotta buy the freaking
chemicals and you gotta go out there and
spend the hours dealing with the thing
uh for a lot less you can take your kids
to the to the another pool
and put them in somebody else's problem
and uh um this is just her hurting and
her wanting to express
love and she just um
doesn't doesn't know how right now and
it's completely inappropriate
and the re and the and the conclusions
that they're all coming to are silly
okay but it's but it's all it's all
sweet and it's all love
and it's all because he was probably
just a great
dad wasn't he yeah he was
yeah 50 years of course i
yeah i don't know i only have my husband
talk to her then
and then we will tell her now's not the
right time yeah
i just think it's a bad idea and and i
think she wants to do something that she
can see the family enjoy
and getting you out of debt is not
something she can see
and do that with and you guys just plow
on through the debt and then later on
when you get ready to do something if
she wants to give you a gift
to do something for the kids and with
the kids i mean
i'm trying to channel my inner john
deloney
and what are you thinking well i
absolutely think you're right here in
this situation there are strings
attached to this gift
and there are strings attached it's
really not a gift it's got all kinds of
conditions
uh it puts you in a situation where
maybe your husband and you could be at
odds because you guys have been walking
out baby step two if i heard you
correctly you're out of debt in october
so you can see the finish line
i think you're right yeah but i think
the most important advice you gave was
that the husband needs to a be on board
with summer
and he needs to deliver that news i
thought that was because she doesn't win
if she delivers that no there's no
there's almost no mother-in-law in the
world that's going to love that
coming i mean that's just a hard thing
and so
you know because and he doesn't even
need to reference summer when he
delivers the message that's the key
to say you know mom i appreciate this
but i'm hurting right now with dad's
passing i know you
are and it's just a bad timing let's
just let's just put this on hold we'll
look at doing it later maybe and
just be very kind and very gentle
because she's really grieving
and and not grieving well by the way uh
when you start throwing money around
like this
right in the face of a loss after 50
years
it's it's a bad sign for how she's
handling this
so she may need to sit down with a
pastor with a good counselor and
just start to walk through the all the
pain because it's legitimate
real pain i mean this is this hurts
and um you don't make financial
decisions in a vacuum ever
you're always affected by your emotions
you're always affected by your
relationships you're always affected by
your
career status everything around you is a
variable affecting your financial
decisions
so there's no one that makes financial
decision space purely on math
it never happens there's always
something going on and it can be good
things or
it could be horrible things tragedies
like this
joy is with us joy is in san diego hi
joy how are you
i am well so happy to talk to you guys
you too
um thank you we have a home that we
raised our kids in
and it is just we own it we own it
outright we are debt free thank you very
much dave ramsey way to go
and we i'm ready to sell and my husband
is too but he keeps going back and forth
you know the holiday market here market
here is great
we can get a nice penny for our home and
walk away
with some money to buy another home you
cannot buy back into
southern california because it costs too
much
we are considering buying in michigan
but then
maybe buying back in southern california
when the market goes down
the question is my husband says maybe we
should keep our home
and rent it no and then we'll okay why
no because you don't need to be
long-distance landlording if you're
moving out of this house it's time to
sell it
um but i'm confused if you sell a home
in southern california why can you not
buy a home in southern california with
that money
because that's pretty much going to be
our retirement although we do have a
nice nest egg
okay so you're not yeah it's not it's
not the southern california thing it's
you don't want to put the money back
into a house and then that's pushing you
out of southern california
so i think you ought to sell it but i
think you probably could just buy
another house there i think you live
there
um and if you want to downsize or right
size or something
i'd probably do that but i would not
move
out of it and rent it that's not going
to work it's not a rental house
it's your home
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey your host
open phones at eight two five five
two two five in orlando florida beth
is on her on the line to do her debt
free scream
hey beth hi how you doing i'm so excited
to be in your show and
this has been amazing so and i wanted to
share with everyone that's why i write
an email and i wanted to for people to
know
how much debt did you pay off beth 121.
love it how long did this take you
took me five years around five years
and i can tell that i started
um i have a friend that's listening
right now she introduced me to dave
ramsey the plan and
she spoke to me at work and i'm like
okay what's that i
have all this debt i don't know how to
do it and i was always struggling
i came from puerto rico with zero with
nothing with my daughter
escaping from a domestic violence
relationship wow to live in a shelter
i used to live in a shelter to protect
myself and my daughter
and when i came with nothing um i was
like
struggling like like a single mom with
just
a job with a thousand dollars it was
back then
and when i started the plan my salary
was around
i would say like 52 000. what is it
kind of like right now i'm 68.
what do you do i work for
a sheriff's office in central florida
i'm right now a community services
coordinator i also am a public
information officer for the state of
florida
and i'm in that law enforcement i teach
self-defense classes
and you save lots of women who are fake
and you save lots of women who are
facing domestic violence like you used
to
correct i opened when i started here
i didn't know english at all i learned
the language i
created a non-profit to help and assist
other women that are going through
domestic violence it's called life in
your hands
and i'm here today free because of you
and i'm so thankful
and i would say that that thousand
dollars
made for me everything because that was
the first step
for me the thousand dollars and i say
okay i can save money how i'm gonna do
it
i start cutting things using the
envelope
system i remember my friends used to
make fun of me
because wherever i went i was i had the
envelopes
and it was fun because that was my goal
i say that
before 50 i wanted to pay it off my
house
and i did it with a lot of sacrifice
this is your house you paid off
i paid off everything my car my
student loan the house what's this now
what's your house worth
right now it's around 180.
so from homeless in a shelter
due to domestic violence to a thousand
dollars to a hundred and eighty thousand
dollar paid for house
a new career and new language skills all
in five years you are an amazing woman
oh but no but i got here before that
many years ago but um in five years
i started everything like the process
with you
yeah no but that took me longer learning
a language is difficult
but i'll say that i follow everything i
paid
the using the snowball and i've been
telling everyone i see everywhere
because i did a video and i shared it in
my social
media that when i paid off the house and
i wanted
people to know that your plan really
works
and the way it it requires a lot
because you have to sacrifice different
things or
trips or vacations but i'll say that
from all the steps the hardest one for
me was the
three to six months expenses
but because it was little by little
trying to get that money
and get it all together how does it feel
now that you're completely debt free
i accomplished and i'm gonna have big
this is
for me it's been everything because i
wanted to show my daughters that you can
do it
so you can live death free because i
remember when i paid off my car when i
was
i i was planning to pay off the car
someone from the family say why are you
paying
that car you need to make payments
monthly so if something happened why are
you going to spend all that money paying
off the car
say i don't want to have no debt and
they couldn't
understand what is leaving that free
and for me was kind of like that made me
kind of like that encouraged me to keep
going
keep going and say no i can do it
everyone's all
they have all that everyone has
something
they have to pay and i want to live
there free
and the other thing was my retirement my
i have the actual retirement from the
state
and in addition to that following your
baby step um i added a 457
tax deferred plan so i have to
so you are going to be the first
millionaire in your family
i don't know about that but i'm working
on it well you're sitting with a 200 000
paid for house and you're loading up
your retirement you're only 50 years old
i think you're gonna make it
no i'm 47 no yeah no yes
you put three extra years on there dave
uh-oh no no
that's not good you're still gonna make
it you're still gonna make it right
beth what does your family think now
those people who are saying why would
you do that why would you do that now
they've seen you on the other side what
kind of impact is it having
for my family they were so thrilled
at my friends as i say i did a video i
recorded a video on my way to the
bank to paid off the house
and i'm i i documented everything
on my way there and i kind of like uh
gave my testimony how god from nothing
zero came here to the states with
nothing
and where he placed me now and as my
testimony kind of like i share it with
everyone the video i edited
at the pictures and all that share with
everyone and
i even wrote it for a newspaper and the
feedback was
amazing people kind of like
sending
your messages life is inspiring i'm
inspired you're so impressive
well done they all asked me like how i
did it and i definitely say
they ran the baby steps and i'm
so grateful i'm so grateful you're a
blessing
and keep doing what you're doing because
it really blessed
us wow you're an incredible lady i'm so
honored to
get to talk to you today absolutely
incredible
very well done so uh are you ready to do
the debt-free scream beth i'm ready
all right i'm under a request in spanish
okay
i don't care you can say you say in
german i don't care
121 000 paid off
house and everything at a mere 47 years
old
did it in five years making 52-68 a life
completely transformed count it down
beth
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
i like that i love it yeah man what a
story
unbelievable what a life what an arc i
mean that's incredible
and you know we find when we did the
millionaire study we find more people
like her
than we do some kind of blue blood uh
you know went to harvard and you know it
had
had all kinds of uh advantages or
something we find we
matter of fact people who come to this
country legally
are four times more likely to become
millionaires than
americans are that grew up here and it's
because they believe
it is the land of opportunity they
believe in the statue of liberty
yeah well you know one of the powerful
things for everybody that becomes debt
free
are the baby steps is just a clear path
for people and they say wait a second
there's an opportunity
to live debt free and she caught that
opportunity from a co-worker
to your point she believed in it and
there's no
stopping anybody there's no the human
spirit is a lie
well holy there are me stopping that
woman she's incredible yeah that's great
beautifully done beth
beautifully done so proud of you you're
an absolute rock star
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 41 13
for i
the lord your god hold your right hand
it is i
who say to you fear not i am the one who
helps you
brian tracy said failure is a
prerequisite for great
success if you want to succeed faster
double your rate of failure well
this is true this is true
ah so how many of you guys are stressed
out or hurting because your retirement
savings scared you to death last year
well if you're in that kind of pain you
may need to have someone to help you
with your confidence
by teaching you and that would be a
smart vester pro
you don't have to let 2020 kill your
confidence text
invest 233 789
find an investment pro in your area
never again face a global crisis alone
text invest two three three
seven eight nine
this is the dave ramsey show thank you
for joining us america
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
joel or joelle is with us in san juan hi
joelle how are you
hi i'm doing great how are you guys
better than i deserve what's up
yeah i was uh calling because uh me and
my wife have been kind of stuck in this
dilemma between
uh deciding and investing um
and what would be essentially an
investment property or
building our first house um so
basically the question is would you guys
recommend buying a multi-family house
where basically we'll be living upstairs
and renting the bottom apartments or
build on a plot of land that we own
um but still oh on because we recently
bought this uh plot of land
okay so you would build what on the plot
of land
a single family so there's nothing
there's no there's nothing
what would you build on it a single
family
yeah okay so the question is at the end
of the story do we end up with a single
family or uh living upstairs in a
multi-family that we rent out
right okay how old are you
um i'm 25. and what's your household
income
we are currently at approximately 85
thousand
yeah all right and um
you have children nope uh but we do plan
on having
uh well in the next few years hopefully
okay all right well quality of life
would be the single
family investing with a lower quality of
life would be living in upstairs in the
multi-family and having your tenants
next door
right the great news is your tenants are
next door the bad news is your tenants
are next door
yeah and from a landlord's perspective
it's um
not always a beautiful thing so um
i mean you got the people all up in your
business and you're all up in their
business
while you're trying to do life now if
you had kids i would push even more
towards a single family
from a quality of life standpoint but
purely on the investment side alone
not considering lifestyle or quality of
life
the multi-family will make more sense
you'll make more money that way
but but it's going to be a pain in the
butt that's part of the deal i mean
you're giving up some things to do that
and
i can tell you this i've owned a whole
bunch of investment real estate
there has not been a piece of investment
real estate that my wife was
wanting to live in
so i've never done what you're talking
about and i own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate today
and i started out like you starting out
here you know with my very first one
so uh it's not a it's not an evil bad
thing for you to build a house on that
piece of land
get it paid off uh save up your money
and buy your first rental
as somewhere else and it's not an evil
and bad thing to move in that
multi-family for a little while pile up
a bunch of cash and then build a piece
of build a house somewhere or buy a
house somewhere and move out and rent
that other
apartment out after you get it all paid
off but uh it's just a matter of how you
all want to live and you need to be real
sure you're listening to
the wife on this yeah i'd pull off the
paper with all the math numbers
and i'd say what's this really going to
be like and and you know it sounds
really good
and walk up there and stand in that
apartment a little bit that's right
just listen to the noises yeah if you've
lived that way before and you and it's
essentially like
you're the uh you know you've rented out
multiple apartments and you're the super
supervisor so i if you can do with that
i if the wife is on board
sure john is in boise idaho hey john
what's up dave kim thanks so much for
taking my call
i was hoping that you guys could help me
out i am trying to figure out if i'm
using math to justify a stupid decision
so uh i'm about to graduate from law
school and also with a master's in
accounting and tax
i'm going to finish with only about
eight thousand dollars in student loan
that day wow
unfortunately you had to get with russia
kovid
last year so well thank you um i
am planning to pay that off within the
first
couple months of starting my job i've
got a great job lined up i'm
gonna be making six figures starting out
which i'm really excited about and i'm
looking to buy a house i'm not in a
position
to have a large down payment though and
i was wondering mathematically being
here in boise
rent prices have gone through the roof i
think we were one of the highest in the
nation
to see an increase in rent prices and
just overall property values have been
going through the roof as well
yep i was wondering if it would be
appropriate for me to
you know get a mortgage or something
with a three and a half percent
down payment and get pmi for a few years
knowing how fast property values are
going up
or you know my dave ramsey alarm is
going off in the back of my head
wondering if i should go the more
traditional route and get
a you know save up a full 20 down
payment if not more
we don't we don't have as a ramsey rule
that you put down 20
on your first house it just saves you
pmi
that's all it does and we just want
people to understand that because
you know the culture has gone uh you
know buy a house when you're broke and
we don't want you to do that
so i i do want you to get the student
loan paid off and have your emergency
fund plus some down payment above your
emergency fund
but a five percent down on a 95 fannie
mae
conventional loan uh will be the
cheapest route to go
you're still going to have the pmi but
it will drop off when you pay it down to
an 80
loan to value and you can do that in
just a few years with your great income
so yeah i'm probably doing that but i'm
not going to do
more than a 15 year and i'm not going to
do a payment that's more than a fourth
of your take-home pay
and i'm not uh you know
and but if you put five percent down
instead of 20 down on a conventional
and you have your emergency fund in
place and you're debt-free i don't have
any issue with it
okay well yeah that makes a lot of sense
i really appreciate the insight
yeah but just keep in mind you're paying
a premium
you know that on that pmi that pmi is a
ripoff
yeah absolutely and i i wouldn't do it
i've worked out the math and
it's not a math thing it's just a stupid
insurance thing that they make you buy
and you want to get rid of it because
you're getting screwed as quick as you
can
that's the thing but it's not okay you
know it's not a matter of i
i don't i don't i just tell people you
know go ahead and buy the house but get
to where this thing can pmi as fast as
you can
uh because it's just foreclosure
insurance that you're buying to protect
the mortgage company pays them if they
have to foreclose on you and lose money
that's all it is you're buying them
foreclosure insurance and it's
75 to 100 a month per hundred thousand
borrowed
and so it's it's a lot and and um
so you know that that's the process
you're in
and uh uh but yeah we don't have a hard
and fast rule 20
down uh especially for first time home
buyers i would hold to that second third
i think you just need to behave
but uh where you're kicking out right
you're starting your life off
you know coming out of school what a
great job though only eight thousand
dollars for student loan debt yeah
really fantastic to come out with that
kind of
degrees and a master's plus the law
degree and he is gonna crush that in two
months
and the sky's the limit uh you're but
you're not opposed to him saying all
right maybe i'll wait a little bit or do
you think because skyrocketing prices
because he can do it you've already
explained that
but he also could wait and not
necessarily it's not the end of the
world white
i think we get the emotions of
skyrocketing prices are
greater than the actual prices that's
why they are skyrocketing this market's
quite high it is i mean there's uh we're
experiencing the same thing in our area
here
lots of these markets are experiencing
this it's just blistering white hot i've
never seen anything like it
uh rental market is full and jammed here
and shooting up fast
and certainly the for sale market is
jammed here and and it is in boise boyce
is a hot market
so there's a bunch of these markets out
there that are that way right now
but just because something goes like
that doesn't mean you walk into the land
of stupid you still do it with the
basics in place
which is what we outlined for john there
well done john
good job brother that puts this hour of
the dave ramsey show in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
[Music]
story
you